wow this chapter is amazing from head to
toe to insane Bonnie powers to gear five
Luffy's return to the fight and his new
powers to who finally shows up at the
end to help the straw hats and the
confirmation that we've been waiting for
in terms of where we're going next after
eggit an insane chapter so make sure to
stay tuned for all that and especially
the twist at the end it's one of the
ones before a break too and you know
those are always especially crazy chill
the parking within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing these one
piece videos and want to keep them
coming make this the video you join the
Naka by subscribing hitting that
notification Bell to turn on all
notifications we are very close at this
point to 2 million subscribers here on
YouTube can't believe I'm saying that so
you can help us reach that insane goal
right now by clicking that button and
now without further Ado let's jump into
It spoilers and all so last chapter we
left off at Bonnie about to be killed by
the pacifistas yes Kuma's original body
was hugging her and thus trying to
protect her but the irony was as Saturn
pointed out that she was about to be
killed by the clones of the very man
that agreed to make clones to save her
Saturn actually takes joy in this tragic
irony saying it's a fitting end for the
insect she is man OD is doing such such
a good job of making him hatable and
laying the groundwork for the Oho
satisfying defeat of this dude anyone
else realize the irony of him calling
others insects while he literally looks
like a spider and yes I know spiders
aren't actually classified as insects
but close enough from a lay man's
perspective before the chapter ended
Vega Punk said something that will be
very important for this chapter he said
when I heard you'd become a pirate
Bonnie there was one awful possibility
that flash through my mind that the Navy
might order the pacifist that's taking
your father's form to shoot his own
daughter without realizing the irony of
it or I guess in this case realizing the
irony of it but savoring it Luffy for
his part said he can't eat anymore at
the end of the last chapter which pretty
much gave us the big clue that he's
eaten enough so that now he can rejoin
the battle and last but definitely not
least a destroyed Marine ship had
Marines on its scrambling to tell kizaru
that quote unquote they whoever they
were went to Egghead and yes everyone
was wrong about who this was although
I'm still hanging on to the hope that
the revolutionaries will join the party
since it would be so perfect and fitting
at this point I mean come on you got the
warrior of Liberation here you got Kuma
here you got Kuma's daughter and the
biological daughter of another important
revolutionary like come on Dragon what
are you doing so that insane Cliffhanger
leads us into this chapter called Always
be on your side and as you might imagine
after the latest chapters it's probably
referring to Kuma always being by
Bonnie's side but then again maybe it's
also referring to our surprise guests
always being on Luffy's side as well the
cover art is Robin dressing up a
crocodile on a beach and I don't always
mention cover stories but one of the top
girls Robin and a kind of shout out to
the alabaster Arc I got to show my vocal
appreciation for that in this chapter
Vega Punk continues where we just left
off he was talking about the possibility
of Bonnie as mentioned being killed by a
pacifista after she became a pirate he
feared this and so Vega Punk did
something Saturn literally told him not
to do when I specifically asked you not
to he risked his life and put a secret
program in all pacifistas based on Kuma
in other words Vega Punk put Bonnie on
top of the pacifistas authority
hierarchy so she's even above the five
Elders Authority wow that's a huge and
amazing reveal one despite all his talk
about being a science this it's funny
how Saturn couldn't actually figure out
that Vega Punk tricked him as he said
he'd be able to do and two massive props
to Vega Punk he definitely seemed aoral
until we met him interested in science
rather than doing what's right but wow
that is the furthest thing from the
truth now and that's clear where he
literally he literally risked his life
and the potential to keep researching in
order to save Bonnie mad respect for
that and I think it's clear at this
point that Vega Punk deserves to be a
straw hat even if that's probably not
his Destiny as a member of the older
generation Vega Punk then says an
absolutely beautiful line he says to
Bonnie even if the whole world is your
enemy your father will never betray you
that's a manly tears level moment right
there Vega Punk also asks Atlas to tell
Bonnie that she has the highest
authority to control pacifistas when
Bonnie says Daddy stop help us to escape
from here and quote all the pacifistas
turn on the Marines what a beautiful
twist and it warms the heart then
finally not great scientist Saturn
realizes what Vega Punk did and he
immediately stabs Vega punkk with his
leg now I'm sure this will be sad but
hard to picture any devastating
long-term consequences because there are
so many Vega punks and backups but if
all Vega clones go then we can start to
panic Saturn orders kizaru to kill all
of them Sanji and Frankie try to stop
kizaru but Frankie is pierced by
kizaru's beam Sanji as one might expect
fares better and blocks one beam But
ultimately he too is pierced by kizaru I
don't think though that he'll stay down
with his newly awakened Powers but we'll
see ioki hes Sanji can get up and
distract kizaru at least while Luffy
deals with Saturn I don't think that
should be too much to ask for at this
point but who knows how Oda wants to
structure this for now though kizaru
goes for Bonnie we've seen this trategy
before by the kisaran Luchi If you
eliminate the higher authority then you
can regain control of the pacifistas but
as Kizer is about to kill Bonnie gear
five Luffy appears to stop him and these
spoilers say like I just said kizaru was
about to kill Bonnie so we have to wait
for the official translations on Sunday
but if that's true the kizaru secretly
being on the straw hat side theory is
not looking good at all I love what
happens next though we are told that
kizar is blown away by Luffy's punch as
if the poor salt on kizaru's wound we're
told it was just a normal hockey punch
not even a new attack Luffy then uses
his powers to turn the ground to rubber
like he's done before and saves everyone
who was falling Saturn then stares at
Luffy in silence we finally seem to be
getting the Luffy versus Saturn fight
being set up here after that we see kizu
sitting on the ground he's holding his
head after being punched by Luffy but
seems fine Bonnie rushes to help Vega
Punk and he reveals to her that Luffy is
NAA the hero she's been waiting for then
an amazing double page spread we see
Bonnie crying and looking at the sky
where Luffy is doing Na's pose the same
one that appears on volume 103 on the
cover and it seems fitting for the sun
god to be in the sky like that as others
look up at him Punk continues saying so
you haven't realized but I also wouldn't
have believed it before witnessing it
with my own eyes that straw Hat Luffy
that had Kuma's attention turns out to
be son God NAA himself Bonnie's like
what and Vega Punk responds Kuma was
right Buster call what good will that do
there are people in this world who have
waited centuries for him end quote and I
love that line think about how much
Terror and meaning the words Buster call
used to carry and now VAP Punk is just
like what good will a buster call do
amazing and as if Vega Punk was talking
about the ancient robot when he said
that there are people in this world that
waited centuries for Luffy the ancient
robot starts to move a little with
Luffy's heartbeat the heartbeat that's
also been called the drums of Liberation
so things are in motion now that's for
sure and maybe I'm just saying this
because all the pacifistas are fresh in
my mind but perhaps like Bonnie can
control the pacifistas moving forward
this suggests that one of Luffy's Powers
is going to be controlling this ancient
robot and perhaps other similar beings
and things like that think Aaron and The
Colossal Titans in the walls and Attack
on Titan I'm sure it won't be as
overpowered as tens of millions of
colossal Titans but still some Beyond
pacifista level creatures or robots
fighting for him would be cool and let
me know in the comments if you have
other theories revolving around this
ancient robot we then cut to the
Northeast Coast of Egghead Island and
Marines report that an unbelievably
large ship is approaching the island
that's a big clue pun intended for who
they are the Marines say it's them no
doubt out but I thought they disbanded
100 years ago end quote so here again we
have people that have arguably waited
over a century for Luffy we hear voices
from a large ship say should we stop and
then no break through in the Epic final
double page and thank you Oda for a
second epic double spread we can see the
Giant Warrior Pirates ship destroying
all Marine battleships in the Northeast
Coast looks like they weren't satisfied
just destroying the kid pirates now
they're going after the world government
we hear the Marines say f fire damn it
why are the Giant Warrior Pirates here
and then the two giants we know so well
are of course leading the Giant Warrior
Pirates and I'm referring to none other
than Dory and brogi who last time we saw
them were also showing off how good they
are at destroying enemy ships the two
literally destroyed the kid pirates
excluding kid himself who had the
privilege of being taken out by Shanks
brgy says look at them Dory they are
asking why we are here Dory says what a
stupid question there's no coincidence
in this world right broggy and so we get
some un expecting and thought-provoking
philosophy thrown in in a moment like
this the Marines are scramming yelling
we have an emergency the Giant Warrior
Pirates have shown up rogy just laughs
saying we're here for you straw hat and
at A Moment Like This I can't help but
think what mihawk said that one time
that Luffy has the most dangerous
ability inti ocean the ability to turn
those he meets into allies he spent some
time with these Giants and now they come
to help him out when he needs it I
imagine all the friends made along the
way will come back into play sooner or
later in this final Saga just like this
and of course with the Giants here
specifically here for Luffy I think it's
clear that yes as we've been hoping for
elbaff will be the next Island we go to
and Dory laughs saying the Sun God and
there are theories that the old dry boy
was a giant just think about that giant
straw hat that we saw before so it's
possible that the Giants will naturally
want to gather around the new dry Boy
AKA Sun God and now if you enjoyed the
amazing family dynamic between Kuma and
Bonnie in this chapter you won't want to
miss my recent video about every Straw's
family tree explained link on screen
right now like And subscribe to help us
reach that insane but close goal of 2
million subscribers here on YouTube and
I'll see you in the next one